what sporty spice up too huh doing a
scene from the boys you [ __ ] I'm not a
[ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] translucent doesn't mean
invisible it means semi-transparent boy
season 2 trailer easily one of the best
things I watched last year and with the
kind of show this is what better sponsor
to have on this video then gpk thanks
for sponsoring this segue bro if you're
a follower of this channel you've heard
us mention gpk before let's face it the
folks who take fandom and creativity to
the next level best known for their
burlesque cabaret show the Empire strips
back set in the Star Wars universe we
read from cover to cover their wookie
erotica magazines which are just like
70s Playboy's but again set in the Star
Wars universe what better way to be one
of the boys than getting lost in one of
these but what I really want to mention
is this book that I read in two days
because it is awesome the Gotham 1919
and 1939 book it takes the characters
and mythology of Batman and reimagine
them as part of depression-era
American history from the war to end all
wars to the crash of the stock market
from enforcement of prohibition to the
rise of celebrity gangster I would love
to see this book a death into a movie or
a TV show but documentary like style
seriously out of all these things like
these products are the perfect thing to
have sponsored this video today so be a
good boy or girl Jon yeah that's fine I
don't know what I was getting so
defensive about and head on over to gpk
today
[Music]
Oh what yeah it makes sense actually
[Laughter]
dude still part of them huh okay whoa
Oh buddy
Oh perfect birthday weekend for Greggy
yeah yes haha oh are you excited is this
a good early birthday tease yes I'm very
very excited you see the boys know
you've recommended a guy I'm sorry
don't vaporize me with your lace what
the hell man lot of stuff out there to
keep track I mainly watch because those
subscribers wanted me to watch it
geez now I'm gonna binge it all tonight
and not sleep until it's one of the most
binge shows ever I mean I like Eric
Kripke of Supernatural Fame from having
reacted to it many times on our patreon
so yes your lack of watching to promote
our patreon page thanks for doing that
you don't use it man well I will take
when I talk when I start talking about
spoilers cover your ears would have been
a great conversation to have beforehand
I never did a review for it I just
watched it on my own time and my
girlfriend you guys were constantly
being like you have to watch the boys I
did so it's funny with the marketing
because they always make it look like
it's only this high octane comedy feels
more like kick-ass right that's what
that's what the trailers always make it
feel like but really it's this amazing
nuanced commentary on like so many
things corporate culture they handle
sexual assault they deal with a lot of
different topics that I don't want to
ruin for I earned this whipping yes it
takes this world of if superheroes were
real how would we monetize superheroes
it's very character-driven it takes its
time a lot more than the trailers of
happy to believe that they always make
it look like it's just like it really
just non-stop fast paced a seller rating
thing I think home Lander is one of the
guy who looks like Superman Captain
America combined I think he's one of the
best villains I've ever seen and film
and TV ever portrayed Oh God he is
brilliant in the show absolutely
brilliant and
okay you should probably cover your ears
John put your fingers in your in your
ear holes well the way the show ended
where you find out that butch his wife
is still alive the kid there and then
you see that one moment where he like
pushes the kid off the roof it's showing
like hey maybe he's doing some type of
weird parent bonding with his superhero
child I think one thing that surprised
me was to actually see that star girl is
still part of the seven I thought by
this point in this series maybe this is
a flashback that are showing us here
she's wearing the outfit that Elizabeth
shoes character was imposing on her to
wear that she was refusing to wear but
and she's rocking it with a whole bunch
of confidence or maybe she's like
undercover and working within the seven
to help out our fellow team you know
considering that the way it ended with a
train at the end of season one you get
glimpses people with some new powers and
whatnot kind of surprised that but maybe
butch escaped home Lander but I would be
under the impression that there's no way
he could do that that only a homeland
her must have let him go for some reason
and I'm curious to see why that is and
the way how season one ended and how
it's this trailer starts off immediately
with showing that the boys are
officially fugitives is in the last
season they weren't really aware of them
and then homeland girl was becoming
aware of the team they didn't people
weren't aware of like oh there's these
people who are trying to infiltrate the
seven and expose that superheroes are
really bad much later on in the show so
to see that they're on the run and they
still have to try to find a way to
complete their mission I feel like it's
just gonna raise the stakes that much
more and yes I did catch a glimpse of
black noir there for a split second he's
awesome he's funny you know they had
that whole thing with Giancarlo Esposito
is character which I don't remember but
I didn't see him at all in the trailer
man that guy between the mandalorian and
the boys and I'm better call Saul he is
just dominating the TV show sphere right
now as I'm editing this I'm like how did
I not talk about this part the fact that
Butch's wife is still alive and and how
that was like his whole motive was to
get revenge for what happened to her and
to see the secret hideout lifestyle she
had what's that gonna do to his
character journey it was his whole
motive season one and that's why he
wanted homeland or dead what level of
confusion or agreement does this lead to
with
in homeland her and what what does that
do with between him and his wife and why
is she doing that there's a lot to
unpack there that it was like the
biggest cooking you're gonna show ended
I'm like those a brother didn't talk
about it all right John you can take
your hands off alright goodness I'm
excited for this I wanted to read the
graphic novels I have heard that those
are like way more like they really
really really push the line across the
line a lot here it's like extremely like
in in areas I don't really care to
images it's just what I ever heard but I
still might give it a shot the show is
so damn good very relevant and such a
wonderful deconstruction in such a
unique way but John sure what's your
take on this trailer I mean blah blah
blah have lots of insight no I mean I do
find it interesting that you've said now
both times because this trailer totally
reminded me of the first trailer for the
first season I liked the trailer for the
first season it got me intrigued to know
that it's not just the pulp because this
does lead heavily with I it's gonna be
fast paced it's gonna be cool and it's
gonna have a lot of action that's gonna
have a lot of production value it's
gonna have a lot of set pieces and stuff
I mean those have that I know I know
another thing is I sitting here
impressed cuz half of me even like on
top of the season one like looking at
how they seem to have grown from that
vague glimpse I have it looks like their
budgets gone up it looks like a
fast-paced fun you know rollicking show
but it makes me happy to hear and it
interests me that much more to hear that
it has those nuances and has that level
of commentary because the trailer itself
doesn't necessarily throw that aspect
out to the forefront ya know it looks
really cool and it looks like it's gonna
at least give a satirical edge on this
kind of material superhero material yeah
to know that you know there's actually
some brains underneath the hood gets
merely it's a real commentary on society
it's more they like they cover religion
it's not just a superhero deconstruction
it's way more than that
and the other boys are also really fun
to watch and then I like that Kimiko I
think it's a surname Kimiko they the
Asian girls part of the game now I'm
excited to see what they do more with
her
character and your boy simon pegg isn't
it - what
yeah my boy is in the pathways Hughie's
fathers yeah it's cool anyway there's a
there's a lot of cliffhangers to uncover
from the last season but how excited are
you guys for the show
Wow it comes up a day after my birthday
like that is such a great way to be like
staining guys watching the bull they
moved Candyman off my birthday yeah guys
what do you think of this trailer any
theories thoughts leave it all down
below Thank You gpk for sponsoring this
video you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification Bell
last but not least let's do up Lance
door Lance my buddy
listen I know you're getting hitched no
you're gonna get married on Lance but
don't forget you know where this is
going oh yeah you got to remain one of
the boys at all times
that means when I go to Canada with you
when there's I'm gonna join your
bachelor party I mean thanks for the
invite dick you didn't buy me a jerk but
thanks for inviting me that I know my
y'all get it if I mean you go that
bachelor party get those strippers I'm
gonna make sure you have one final
policy baby she's not she's not
I mean I'm not going to just for safety
in case you watch of course I wouldn't
either just to be a good influence on it
I'm not even gonna make the joke we're
gonna respect those strippers
about wedding don't forget to still
party with those other firefighting boys
as many Boies references as i can make
make sure yeah yeah get another one in
the oven so you could have another boy
with your woman see you buddy boys